if you really want to train like batman
then you need to eat sleep and recover
like batman
because seriously although the training
programs as described in the comics and
the batman files and the films
are extremely impressive completing them
wouldn't be the really big challenge
the real challenge would be to complete
those training programs then to fight
crime all night and to get barely any
sleep
get beaten up and then to run wayne
enterprises the next day
he's got barely any breaks barely any
time to sleep and he's got to somehow
continuously push himself and maintain
optimal performance
so you just know that bruce wayne's
gonna have the most advanced diet most
advanced techniques and supplements to
ensure that he can maintain that kind of
output without burning out
and just becoming this injured wreck and
whilst this is just a bit of nerdy fun
whilst it's just a bit of a thought
experiment it is something that can
apply to many of us because so many of
us
struggle to maintain our training thanks
to our packed work schedules
our commutes our other responsibilities
around the house our social lives etc
how can you continue to train at your
best especially as you get older
when you have so many other pressures on
top of you because this is what so many
people don't understand so many of us
think of rest as being time away from
the gym
if you're not at the gym then you're
resting so it's very hard to become over
trained
recovering doesn't just mean not
training if you're highly stressed at
work if you're playing with the kids if
you're commuting to the office if you're
tidying the house or if you're
socializing those are all
physiologically stressful
events they're all going to keep you
aroused so that you're not properly able
to recover
and heal so you need to actively recover
and especially as you get more busy and
you need to find strategic ways
to get the optimal recovery the optimal
fuel when you're not training and this
is something i've been experiencing a
lot recently so i have some exciting
news to share with you guys
my wife and i are actually expecting our
second child soon
and she's several months pregnant now
which is exciting and brilliant but
unfortunately she's also been suffering
with a lot of morning sickness which has
meant that i've been
taking over the duties looking after our
daughter emmy
who's two and a half years old and is
just full of energy so at the moment
i've been waking up early with her
playing all morning
getting her ready making breakfast and
looking after the house then putting her
to bed
working for two hours then waking her
back up again and
doing the whole thing all over again
going to baby class she's not going to
sleep till like nine because again she's
a two and a half year old
and that's why at the moment despite
having made the binary my full-time job
i haven't
yet been able to increase the output of
my content etc
quite as much as i'd like to so the
point is that whilst i might not work in
an office and whilst i
might appear to be a youtuber who just
gets paid to work out the truth is that
i actually struggle a lot to fit in my
training and run the business
as well just like many of you guys and
especially at the moment so
some of these hacks some of the things
i've tried in the past have been really
effective at helping me to cope with
that and to manage my energy levels and
my
work-life balance and hopefully it can
do the same
for you guys go batman or go home
so let's start with sleep because this
would be a huge area for bruce wayne to
consider
after all authors like matthew walker
who wrote the book why we sleep
describe sleep as this kind of
non-negotiable performance enhancing
strategy in the eyes of many
neuroscientists there's simply no
substitute for sleep
it helps you to concentrate better
improves your mood your focus your
reaction times
creativity it helps restore your muscles
and helps you to repair damage from
training
someone like batman who pushes himself
so far so hard
is really going to need a lot of sleep
but unfortunately his schedule just
simply
doesn't allow for that sort of thing the
good news is is that a lot of the
studies that
people like matthew walker point to
whilst demonstrating the negative
effects of sleep deprivation
aren't introducing alternative
strategies to try and mitigate those
effects
so the question for us then is if we
have no option but to reduce sleep
what other methods can we use to
essentially reduce
the negative effects that this would
have and that's where things get pretty
interesting
so i've seen it suggested numerous times
and it is logical that
batman might use something like a
polyphasic sleep
schedule such as the famous uberman
schedule
here instead of sleeping for one large
chunk you instead split your sleep into
multiple smaller naps in the case of the
uberman schedule
this is something like 20 minutes done
six times throughout the day for a total
of two hours sleep that gives you 22
hours
of wake time so imagine the training and
the detectivating that you could do
with those hours this is just one
schedule there are some that are
slightly less intimidating
uberman is one of the slightly more
daunting
there aren't that many studies looking
at the effects of polyphasic sleep in
the long term
although what i could find was generally
positive and suggested that it could be
sustained
likewise there are lots of anecdotal
reports from people who have practiced
these kinds of sleep schedules
saying that actually gives them a sense
of euphoria and maybe even more energy
than they normally experience
what we need to remember is that in
order for polyphasic sleep schedules to
work
you need to be really strict with your
schedule you need to allow your body to
adapt
to your new rhythms and this is
something that's going to be a problem
for most of us
even if you're good at doing it 90 of
the time if you have one day out one
holiday
then suddenly this becomes an issue and
for batman whose
life is constantly throwing him
curveballs he's not going to be able to
easily take power naps you know in the
middle of a fight with the joker
and for that reason i don't think the
polyphasic sleep is probably the answer
for batman
what's seemingly counterintuitive about
something like the uberman schedule
though
is that you're only sleeping for those
brief 20-minute windows and this doesn't
allow us to go through a full
sleep cycle which most psychologists
think is necessary for us to get the
full restorative benefits
of sleep a lot of people on this
schedule so they go straight into rem
sleep because obviously
this is at the end of a normal sleep
cycle and they're clearly not getting
enough of it but what's really
interesting is that some indigenous
tribes
also sleep for brief spells like this
the peraha tribe only sleep for 20 or 30
minutes at the time
and they believe that if they sleep any
longer they'll actually lose their souls
upon waking
obviously the paraha are an entire tribe
of people and with no obviously negative
effects
this seems to suggest that it is
possible to reduce sleep or at least
negotiate the strict hours that we sleep
during
perhaps we just need to learn more in
order to do this in a safe and healthy
manner
so if like batman you absolutely can't
get your full eight hours of sleep
perhaps not all hope is lost what can
you do to ensure that the hours you do
get
get you the maximum bang for your buck
well we can learn one thing from looking
at that piraha tribe
and others like it actually there are a
great number of indigenous tribes that
don't sleep the full eight hours
many of which seem to have no negative
effects whatsoever
the interesting thing is we long assumed
that due to evolutionary forces
all these tribes should fall asleep at
roughly the same time once it starts
getting dark however what researchers
have actually found
is that many of them like us stay up
long after the sun is set the one
predictor of bedtime that does seem to
be true across
many different cultures however is
temperature the tribes
start to wake up once the temperature
reaches its lowest point in other words
as soon as the temperature starts rising
they start to wake up this is a very
important
external zeitgeber also known as a time
giver
it helps us to set our biological clock
in other words
we've always known that light is
important for this but so too is
temperature
and if you're sleeping in a climate
controlled environment with your window
closed and the heating on then perhaps
you're starving your body of one of the
vital cues it needs
to regulate its own clock so perhaps one
of the best things you can do to wake up
feeling more refreshed is to sleep with
the temperature off and the window open
this small hack could just improve your
sleep and we do know that sleeping in a
cooler temperature
is much better for our thermal
regulation leading to deeper
and more restorative sleep
so even more batman like might be to try
and replace your sleep with meditation
again we're not trying to completely get
rid of sleep sleep is still the
preference
but if you can't get enough sleep then
meditation might be the next best thing
there are actually studies showing that
meditation can reduce sleep need
and that's both in the short term where
a bit of meditation can help you do cope
through the day improving mental
vigilance and reaction times and focus
and also in the long term where you see
that experienced meditators actually
need
less sleep or at least they appear to
sleep less one study titled
meditation acutely improves psychomotor
vigilance and may decrease sleep need
concluded that these results suggest
that meditation provides at least a
short-term performance improvement even
in office meditators
in long-term meditators multiple hours
spent meditation are associated with a
significant decrease
in total sleep time when compared with
age and sex matched controls who did not
meditate
whether meditation can actually replace
a portion of sleep or pay off sleep debt
is under further investigation in that
study they used a form of concentrative
meditation
from yoga but this is something else to
consider is that there are actually lots
of different types of meditation
and they might have different benefits
in particular non-concentrated
non-directive
forms of meditation where you don't
necessarily try and focus on your breath
but you just let your mind intentionally
wonder like daydreaming
these seem to actually more closely
mimic the effects of rem sleep
they help us to organize our thoughts
when you're daydreaming that's what
you're doing you're consolidating
memories
organizing thoughts coming up with new
ideas you're just allowing yourself to
explore
different connections and different
memories conversely using meditation
that
does involve calming the mind by
concentrating on breathing
or relaxing the body such as a body scan
meditation
these methods might be more effective at
simulating the effects of slow wave
sleep
sws so perhaps the perfect meditation
protocol if you're trying to reduce
sleep need would be to combine these
different types of meditation
then you have specific types of
meditation that are well known for their
ability to
reduce sleep need such as yoga nidra
which is something that andrew hubermann
talks about on his podcasts and there
are some studies demonstrating that this
is
certainly effective to a degree in one
study it was shown that a short bout of
yoganedra meditation
could restore dopamine levels in the
basal ganglia and this is
one measure we can use to look at
fatigue related to sleep deprivation
so there's some promising research
around this and you could certainly
imagine batman using meditation
as a way to try and perform his best on
minimal sleep and this is something that
i've used lately
if i'm really tired and i've had several
days of sleeping for just five hours
because keep in mind that sleep
deprivation
is a cumulative effect as much as
anything else then i might try using a
quick five or ten minute meditation
and this can help me to perform better
so this is the muse 2
headband and i think the main great
thing about it is that it's a fashion
statement
seriously though this device is a
neurofeedback device it uses eeg that's
electroencephalography
in order to monitor your brainwaves
during meditation
this is then used to give you feedback
whilst you meditate via headphones or
via your phone's speaker
basically telling you whether your mind
is calm or whether you're starting to
drift off and let your
mind race this little nudge then allows
you to bring yourself back to focus
to calm yourself and that in theory can
help you to progress
faster in meditation and get more
minutes racked up of
quality meditation it has a bunch of
other cool features as well it's got a
heart rate monitor built in
of course it's not essential if you want
to start meditating and i'm going to
give a full review in future
like any device it has its quirks
however i think it's very cool i've
definitely enjoyed using it it makes
meditating more fun
and i think it's the kind of thing that
batman would definitely be experimenting
with looking his own brainwave in order
to achieve
a calm state of focus if you want to try
out the muse 2 headband then you'll find
a link in the description down below and
if you click on that and use my
code you'll also get a discount and i
get a small commission as well so you'll
be supporting the channel
i appreciate it very much this is not a
sponsored video by the way i actually
reached out to them it was just
something cool that i was trying
and i wanted to share with you guys
sometimes i've just bio hack something i
think a lot of people could benefit from
and certainly bruce wayne
is sunlight exposure and the related
topic of
photobiomodulation or red light therapy
there are a ton of huge benefits to
exposing yourself to sunlight
especially large surface areas of skin
studies show that this can elevate
testosterone in particular this is
partly through increased vitamin d
production
which at the same time is also going to
strengthen your bones and support your
immune system
and generally it's now thought that
vitamin d is significantly more potent
than even vitamin c
when it comes to strengthening your
immunity this might sound like a minor
deal but
getting a cold or generally feeling
under the weather is gonna
put you out of action for a seriously
long amount of time could you imagine
batman fighting bane whilst dealing with
you know the flu or the sniffles
at the same time this also helps to once
again set your circadian rhythms
so that you sleep better at night and
feel more energetic during the day
especially if you get morning sunshine
in fact as andrew hubermann talks about
if you're suffering with
sleep deprivation or jet lag or night
shift work one of the best things you
can do to
set your clock straight is to get early
morning sunlight particularly in the
eyes
which will help to set those circadian
rhythms and trigger the production of
the right neurotransmitters so that your
body knows what's going on and knows to
wake up
and provide you with energy throughout
the day but it might also go a little
bit further than this because you also
get some red light from the sun
and studies show that red light exposure
in particular can also boost
testosterone
encourage healing and all sorts of other
really cool things really early studies
show that if you expose
large surface areas of skin to red light
and particularly the testicles actually
this can drastically increase
testosterone and this works in a
different way
from just raising vitamin d it actually
boosts and encourages
mitochondrial performance these being
the energy factories of the cell
or the powerhouses of the cell as
everyone likes to say and this also
affects the leydig cells
which in turn results in a massively
elevated testosterone boost
other research looking at red light
therapy is also really positive it can
encourage blood flow which at the same
time can
improve healing and it generally
stimulates energy production so
this is something that i could imagine
batman doing in his home having a big
wall of red light it's not something
i've personally experimented with yet
i would like to but in the meantime just
getting more sunlight
you know training outdoors and taking
your top off from time to time can be
really good
this is actually something i think makes
intuitive sense many of the people that
i've known
in my own life who have the most energy
and seem the healthiest
are the outdoorsy types people who are
surfers or like riding mountain bikes or
hiking these people just seem to have
boundless energy
and there might be a good reason for
that you see there is a reason for all
of the gratuitous nudity on this channel
so that's it for part one guys this
video was getting so long i decided i'd
split it into two parts here we talked
about sleep and recovery
and next time i'm going to be talking
about diet supplements and bio hacks
that
bruce wayne or someone who trains
intensely might use in order to
help themselves push themselves further
hope you found this useful and
interesting if you did guys then please
leave a like and share around
that helps me out immensely likewise
leave any comments below
let me know what different strategies
you use to get the most out of your
sleep especially
when you don't have enough time to sleep
properly if you like the idea of
training
and biohacking not only for strength but
for cognitive performance and for better
sleep and
agility and flexibility and endurance
then you might enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training
you'll find that in the description down
below and there's a discount on right
now whilst we're dealing with a pandemic
likewise like i said you can also find a
link to the muse 2 headband if you're
interested in that
i also have a print book out it's called
functional training and beyond and there
i discuss
functional training and what it means
for the general population as well as
athletes so
that serves as a great introduction i
hope either way thank you so much for
watching for supporting the channel for
subscribing it really means a lot to me
and i'll catch you next time
bye for now